I suggestin you are taking look at
Pokemon Sun and Moon for us and your
review and progress went up late last
night this morning early this morning
okay it's up on site now and not a lot
we can talk about unfortunately not a
lot of specific details can talk in very
broad strokes about the new mechanics
and where the story is is kind of
heading we are under embargo for
specific stuff after I think basically
the third island but I think if you
tried out the demo for the game you all
you've already gotten a good feel for
some of the big changes they've made to
the game yes so quality of life stuff
for the most part that kind of a big
thing I think that's the most immediate
like as someone who's played a lot of
the games when you come into it
mechanically it feels very very
different in a incredibly positive way
like every game has played around with
the way the menus work and trying to if
you know it feels like they try to make
things a little bit easier but this is
the first one where it's like these
changes are not only really sweeping but
super positive I think one of my
favorite the thing that stood out for me
the most is that after you meet a
creature for the first time when you
meet any creature a second time you can
see immediately looking at your your
attacks what's effective what's not
effective what's gonna have no effect
like that was always so annoying to me
when you come up against a guy in you're
like well i have a new move or which
this one's this is a steel fairy and i'm
a dork electric should i use ghost gosh
so but by and large this is pokemon
right like so much of it is I'm sure the
same right Jake let me jump to you
you've been playing a little bit I've
been playing quite a bit i'm not quite
as far as he is ok but i think one of
the big sort of structural differences
of the fact that there's not aight gym
leaders this time around and people who
have been following this notice already
but instead there's four islands i think
right in each island has a certain
amount of trousers you need to complete
before you go to the final trial and I
dad once you do four of them I don't
know what happens after that can we do
so does not like the broad big story
like what are you actually doing here if
you're not trying to become the best
that you can be so you are trying to
become the left
you're you're in a different set so now
there are four main islands right and
there is a really strong trainer on each
island who is called the Kahuna good yes
it's a hawaiian-themed and you have to
you have to build up to fighting the
Kahuna when you fight the Kuno you're
like well you're you're the best dude
you're the best girl if you choose to
create a girl I actually play as a girl
on my Pokemon adventure but you you
become the best in that island in the
you can move on to the next Island and
face these new trials and the trials
themselves are set up similar to gems
and I think we you know we saw a little
bit of variety with what you can do in a
gym in previous games but this one takes
it in a very very different direction
for one when you go through some of
these trials some of them will be
quizzes like it's not necessarily just
here are three trainers and you fight
them and maybe do a little bit of a
minigame and then move on to the the
final guy and he'll give you the badge
and everybody has Rock pokemon like
there can be a kind of a variety of
different pokemon that you'll fight with
in these trials sometimes you have to
take pictures of them there was one that
has to take pictures it's it's not quite
pokemon snap but they're in this is
something that we saw in the demo is
well where you would go into an area and
you have to look into like this little
rock wall and there's a Pokemon who's
walking buying you have to try to can
take a picture of him with your camera
okay which is like it's 48 it's changing
it up and the other thing is you're not
actually fighting trainers in these
battles you're fighting pokemon directly
like these are just pissed off Pokemon
and you're gonna find them on their own
and one of them once you reach the end
of the trial is gonna be a super powered
up version why are these poke wants so
angry ha island life you know you're
gonna island fever it's well they're you
know they're being really relaxed and
then you're coming in you're intruding
on their vacation time I'd be kind of
pissed off to make it super powered up
with their Z move so that's it I guess
the other new mechanic which it kind of
bears resemblance to mega evolutions and
stuff they've played around with it in
other previous games but now that you
have these Z moves and the pokemon that
you find in these trials also have the
super powered up Z move ability I
actually don't use a lot mostly because
the first thing that I do when I play
any Pokemon game is turn off all battle
animations because it takes such a long
time like I want to get through this
it's true I do it too and so but the Z
move even if you turn off battle
animations you still have to watch that
30 seconds it's it's like knights of the
round is it not I mean it's not actually
that bad but it is it is that feeling of
well now I have this superpower I'm not
gonna use this superpower to move just
cuz it takes so long to watch it do they
do they show you the strength of those
two cuz like I used one on like a on a
powered up pokemon or whatever and it
was supposed to be super effective and
it didn't do much nicer she's like ember
and it didn't want I was like alright
never using that again so the
super-powered move you have is usually a
reflection of one of your other moves so
it'll tell it'll generally say like
which one that so the thing that you
equip is equipped to a certain type of
move so they're in the names for these
are totally dumb it's like normally mz4
normal moves and if you touch into a
pokemon fire mmm easy bug am iam Z like
fur bug moves when you attach it to that
how we rope you're not that evil Darth
but gain EMC is for dark yeah get a
straight Jason so you know like oh if I
use this specific move it'll powered up
and then for each of your the starter
Pokemon they also have a crystal for
that specific Pokemon so i started with
owlette who turns into duodecim and you
have get do adesso MZ to power up his
ghost move how do you fill out the
starters this time around are they as
lovable as a Bulbasaur as a Charmander
oh no like it they're never gonna be as
lovable as as the originals but I really
like the owl because he's adorable
thinking he's a little bowtie as owls do
i think the weird thing with pokemon is
that whenever you look at the way that
they're dressed the way that they're
outfitted the way that we think about
them being outfitted is those aren't
outfits that's a part of their biology
so it's like when you look at a cute cat
you like all the way his furs grown it
looks like he has eyebrows in a boat i'm
like well when you look at this owl that
looks like he has a like a nice bowtie
that's something that's protruding from
his skin like it's really flaps of skin
popping out all right haha tight um can
we talk about how many pokemon are in
this game I think they've said that
there's think they've said but I don't
know it's something over seven that
they've added a bunch of new Pokemon and
I think the current number is well over
700 are they benefiting from continually
adding so many pokemon game after game
or
I felt that for a long day yeah I my
brain like I can't fit any more Pokemon
names in my head after like the 3rd
generation like I just seemed like a
cool another one the issue is they keep
adding new poking lil especially in the
beginning like you would have yeah the
first game then the second game was like
well we need to have a whole new set of
Pokemon but you know those first Pokemon
were pretty good let's just make a copy
of those and it felt really similar like
you start out with oh I met shitty rat
oh here's crappy bird and then the third
game was like oh well let's let's make
another dumb rad and another dumb bird
you hate raspberries I'm with you though
yes it's it's so this one's definitely
better I think x and y did similar
things and outro mega Ruby and alpha
sapphire of course like introduced a lot
of reintroduced the same Pokemon you saw
before but even as the new games they've
realized while we have to go with the
ones that you're familiar with on the
ones you like and the new ones that we
introduced have to be a little bit
different and one of the things they're
doing different with Sun and Moon are
variants on existing Pokemon and they've
shown shown somewhat like you have
dugtrio as this like long hair luscious
hair brushes hair and I think it's a
steel-type now instead of ground make
sense I I don't know which ones I can
specifically talked about and not talk
about but I know that one I can I know
they've showed the right you already
this is right you different I've it I
haven't caught it right you well I think
it's still the same okay right I feel
like they've seen it live showed Reimer
and drummers fight it out pokemon battle
it out come on primer is like a
completely different type it's not
poisoning and that's also a little bit
sard garbage though yeah literally
colors I got a total of garbage colorful
puddle garbage it's a cool band name if
you guys are a little tired of all the
new pokemon why do you keep playing I
wouldn't save all hired team skull
because every time they show up they'd
like look so stup I don't know man they
like I don't know if I should hate them
or like kind of like oh I don't know
what do you think about the way they
talk because this was something we also
saw in the beginning of the game you saw
in the demo they have a very distinctive
I
I don't know if I kids it's going like
watching Breaking Bad and a Jesse the
Jesse character yeah they're like Jesse
do man yo dawg I got beaten up coming
homie like hunt but they're all like
super white yeah like oh he just wrecked
us but in general like has as in 10 doge
and the pokémon company reached that
logical conclusion at this point I feel
like they kind of have like maybe a
couple games ago like well I mean a
logical creative conclusion maybe in
some ways but not a logical sales
conclusion because yeah but from your
perspective you're not trying to give
them money you're trying to have a game
that you enjoy and play it because
there's something new about it like do
you really feel like it's the new things
that are bringing you back or is it just
nostalgia for Pokemon I feel like four
previous games it was definitely
nostalgia and Omega Ruby and alpha
sapphire most of my enjoyment from it I
think it had some nice additions to the
to the series but it was primarily
nostalgia that kept me going along on
that whereas Sun and Moon definitely
feels like big additions that needed to
be brought to the game for a long time
and if someone if you haven't played for
a long time I feel like this is a good
way to get back into it if you've always
hated Pokemon if you like I've tried it
and pokemon is about catching and
leveling up monsters and that's really
boring but it still is like that core
nugget of what the game is about is
still the same it's just now it's a it's
a more it's a better game it feels like
it's it's tighter it's more streamlined
it's taking out a lot of the things that
it felt like they held onto just because
well we've been doing the series for a
long time and that's the way we used to
do it so let's keep doing it the boring
way right it feels like they've solved
that in a lot of ways there are to many
pokemon I think if you're coming into
this for the first time like that's just
going to be overwhelming but you know
even coming at it from from a review
perspective where I'm trying to play as
much as I can as quickly as possible it
adds to the feel of each area that
you're not running into the same Pokemon
over and over again like that each area
even within these odd these islands can
feel very distinctive because i'm
running into pokemon that are familiar
Pokemon deter new and each island has
its own diverse
ecology in that way that's very good
point Jake any input I agree with what's
inside I mean I've I've played all the
pokemon games and I've been looking
forward to this for a while and I I
agree like it definitely feels way more
streamlined but I think part of the
reason why I'm still playing pokemon
games is because they don't come out
that often right it's like the last was
three years ago so like if there's one
every year I would definitely get sick
of this formula so fast because it is
repetitive it's very repetitive but like
I'm feeling like playing a Pokemon yeah
but feeling like playing one for a while
now so sun and moon is scratching that
itch yeah and it's something i don't
necessarily want on a bigger console
like they wait long enough to bring them
out that it's usually it's years between
releases but it's something that fits
really well with their portable systems
and it's something that wouldn't that
definitely wouldn't be as much fun on a
full console both because i like to play
it in kind of short spurts and i like to
be able to share that experience with
friends well like nintendo switch can
change up that formula drastically
because it is potentially a console that
will be more portable in some ways and i
admit it would be nice to look at it in
a little bit more HD the game looks
better but it's still a little pixelated
around the edges like it could be cooler
on switch but the the experience that
they have now like graphics aren't as
incredibly important and just that
experience of sharing with friends and
playing on around a new island with new
pokemon it's it's fun alright and your
full review should be coming shortly
after launch this friday alright well
you can check out justin's review in
progress right now on gamespot com come
back later in the week for his full
review